ok this is a Diamond digger saga totems
levels tutorial video just going to talk
about the fourth and final level
requirement start some level 71 and as
you can see fireflies levels have a
firefly points levels have the diet of
the diamonds in the bubble twenties
levels have the rubber ducky nintendo's
levels habita so these are the kind of
the trickiest levels especially when you
first get to them so we'll go over them
and talk about how they work I'm just
going to go ahead and skip this alright
so you see the goal is to bring down
three totems these other totems right
here so it says bring the totem to its
base you do that by making matches
underneath it and removing all the
ground blocks as you can see it'll fall
right down and so that's what we got to
do so just work from the top on this one
at least part two part of the way when
we can just need to get the diamonds to
line up now sometimes these take some
planning like here we could probably get
away with not paying attention but you
can see that this blue match is going to
take out these two and now we're going
to have a pink in the bottom and so what
I'm going to do is I'm going to make the
green match first so that I know that
these pink ones will fall and I'll be
able to match them up there and you see
how it does that and so definitely
that's why these are a little bit
tougher first because you can get stuck
where you can't have a match underneath
so just pay attention to how they're
going to fall
and this is the same we see we have to
get three only difference here is is
that these are ground blocks are going
to take more than one hit so I'm just
going to
oh you see I kind of went around it a
little bit and the reason I did that was
to make sure that we had some space
underneath so that way when we'll get
stuck and we'll drop it down lock the
lock opens up once it falls that there's
just one of them and then you can move
on to the metro
I think now is probably a good time to
use the color burst even though we have
nine moves left might as well get out
here as fast as we can but I'll give us
more blended points at the end and
that'll do it that's an easy one of
course you run into some that are very
difficult totems are like I said I think
the worst so we'll look at some other
other ones real quick as mentioned the
most important thing is just to plan a
little bit more when you're playing a
totems level because you don't want to
get stuck look at some of the harder
levels give you an idea how that happens
whenever there's a lot of space around
especially on both sides it's pretty
easy to make set make matches but this
level you'll see it doesn't it doesn't
have those on some of the killings and a
lot of the later time levels that are
really tough that's why they are tough
because you need to get diamonds the
ball exactly right and they don't always
cooperate so that room was easy but the
second one has it has one of the ones i
was talking about so right here whenever
you have one that's like this in a tight
space you really want to pay attention
so that you don't get stuck below this
isn't a bad set at this so we can
probably just work our way down
alright so see this is what happens
there's no matches i can make below it
and this is blocked here so there's
really no way to get more diamonds down
there either so those are the sorts of
things that can make these really
difficult and I'm just moving on things
around here but about like when this
happens like your chances are completing
a level or pretty much they're pretty
much out the window and I'm just going
to show you we have 15 moves right here
i'm going to show you how bad this
actually I bad the situation actually is
so we can make a match here okay and
then we can make another one there
alright so now that's blocked so as you
can see there's really nothing we can do
we can sort of work our way and get the
booster charged and now we can you know
get rid of it like that which can be
okay at some NGO on some levels if
you're stuck and you know you're stuck
you you might want to just hard to
booster but here now there's two more
rooms in this level and we only have six
moves left so I guess we got lucky here
so we can we can drop all three of these
as we go but that's that's not always
going to happen either so
and then we only have five moves left
and we need our booster to get rid of
these so that shows how important
planning can be with these things now
for as hard as they are totems are
pretty straightforward there's really
not much more they always drop straight
down the ones that are in rooms that
have pardon me that have ground blocks
of different types just take more hits
to clear out the bottom of so the one
last thing I'm going to go over real
quick to keep this video kind of short
is totems with lava levels and if you
haven't seen while the blocks yet we'll
just talk about how those work so we
have so you've started out with three
and then I grow as as on each match that
you make so what you have to do is you
have to get water to them first in order
to you'll see once we do it
in order to stop them from growing you
see how that happens so we have we have
these blocks that are like scorched I
guess you could say and they take two
gets to clear out so whenever you run
into a level like this you want to leave
the water to the law as fast as you can
in almost all cases because the you know
the longer you wait and this one's a
little bit more complicated here the
longer you wait the more it grows so
just watch how the lava can sort of take
over
but that's all you really have to do as
you can see then we have these e of
their narrow spaces but at the same time
we only have two colors here so it's
really not as as toughest like the board
we were stuck on before and you can just
drop them now so yeah there's a lot of
different things to come up with them
totems but we have individual guides for
the levels that help you to get through
the tough ones so I think that's a basic
understanding of how they work if you
have any questions leave a comment here
or join our group you can leave comments
there and that's one of the fastest way
to get in touch with us and then also on
our website we check those comments all
the time to you and let us know what you
need help with because that helps us
make a better website if you found this
video helpful please like it that helps
us and we'll be making more how to
videos with commentary soon so be on the
lookout thanks